me acuerdo me acuerdo que cuando era
niño dibujaba empezando en mis zapatos y
continuaba por mi pierna y continuaba
dibujando y dibujando
sabes mi papá realmente no quería que
hiciera muchas cosas artísticas él era
más del tipo de o deberías intentar la
arquitectura o algo así y yo tuve que
probarle que había ingresos que si podía
vivir del arte y lo que descubrí fue que
se podía combinar arte con tecnología
relacionado con el mundo en el que
vivimos ahora porque había más trabajos
con mejor estabilidad y cosas así
entonces cuando estaba haciendo sitios
web a vi animaciones si eso que le das
click a un botón y hace una pequeña
animación y para mí fue como oh qué es
esto de la animación y después me dio
más y más curiosidad y después conforme
mis sitios web iban mejorando y
mejorando fue como oh qué tal si hago un
logotipo que gire en 3-d pero como hago
cosas en 3d fui a una presentación de
trabajos muy importante en donde todas
las escuelas de arte revisan los
portafolios de los estudiantes y yo
tenía algunas cosas en 3-d pero
realmente yo me decía soy un artista y
resulta que tengo un poco de esto en mi
portafolio y me dijeron tú necesitas
hacer 3d y yo dije 3
y que me dijeron no animación en 3-d por
computadoras yo no sabía mucho sobre
tecnología así que en la universidad yo
era como una esponja y si aprendí mucho
en la universidad en la escuela teníamos
que hacer un cortometraje de dos minutos
y medio y el mío fue sobre el guardián
de un faro el mecanismo que lo encendía
necesitaba reparación porque se había
congelado y entonces un barco se va a
estrellar contra la roca en la que él se
encuentra ya de intentar repararlo se
electrocuta y muere
se levanta como fantasma y trata de
arreglar el interruptor
pero como es un fantasma pasa a través
de él y resulta que cuando suena la
bocina del barco el voltea
y ve su cadáver y se queda impactado
necesita recuperarse rápido porque si no
lo hace el barco se va a estrellar
entonces se da cuenta que puede entrar
en la lente que amplifica la luz así que
brinca la lente y explota en luz y
finalmente el barco puede ver las rocas
y logra evitarlas
yo creo que había varios aciertos y
destellos ahí me divertí mucho creando
mi personaje y cuando quise ingresar en
pixar
yo estaba solicitando un trabajo
diferente pero ocurrió que tenía un
pequeño vídeo de mi personaje moviéndose
y haciendo varias expresiones faciales y
entonces me dijeron te queremos para
hacer rigging y yo dije que es rigging
entonces rigging también conocido como
articular es básicamente diseñar una
interfase con un montón de botones que
se mueven es como mover el personaje
para que pestaña con sus párpados y
cosas así
me encanta ser robots y me encanta hacer
robots porque es una continuación de lo
que me encanta de pixar que es hacer que
los personajes estén vivos en la mente
de las personas y para mí la robótica es
como isi qué tal si no solo pudiera
hacer que los personajes fueran reales
solo por dos horas y si pudiera ser que
sean reales por más tiempo incluso por
muchos años y pues sí es muy emocionante
trabajar en un montón de cosas de las
que no sé porque literalmente yo vengo
del arte pero también está la ingeniería
mecánica la ingeniería eléctrica las
ciencias de la computación la
fabricación y hay muchísimas cosas que
no conozco y literalmente solo he
aprendido a través del internet
no he tomado ninguna clase y porque
aprendo visualmente
siempre busco en youtube primero porque
para mí los vídeos son lo que más me ha
enseñado
y el texto bueno ese lo uso como un
recurso cuando no hay tanto material en
vídeo
y entonces es como un experimento con
robots y humanos
y el tipo de interacciones que podemos
tener con un ser artificial y eso es
genial